You were recommended a healthy mouth blend in my updated protocol.
I noticed that it does contain some mint oils.
I'm supposed to not have mint within an hour of my mobile pathic drops.
Is there enough mint in this product that I need to make sure that I leave an hour
between brushing with this and taking my homeopathic drops?
The answer is yes.
Yes, there is.
That's the same thing with any other toothpaste, too.
If you have a mint flavored toothpaste, remember you should not be using any
holyopath within about an hour of that.
So, mint, spearmint, peppermint can negate the effects of holyopathic drops.
So, you don't want to be doing mint, uh,
the lost edges, you don't want to be doing mint toothpaste within about 30 to 60
minutes of taking a holyopath.
So, just be careful of that.